you also say that there's almost no one
who has had as much power to hurt you is
yeah yeah and I'm you know perhaps that
is because he's someone that like I said
you know when you find family and your
friends in the street I looked for my
friends to be my family I look to them
for all the support and my sense of self
and for the encouragement and for the
things you want from family you know and
it's just like you know the way that
your parents can really hurt you because
the trigger they know these buttons it's
like that for me with my friends and
with him because you know we are so
close and we are family and it's always
been that way you know that I've you
know deeply emotional connections that
that are vulnerable and that are fragile
that can be the most heartwarming you
know encouraging supporting things in
the world and can be really
disappointing and hurtful and because I
look for them to be so much and you
didn't read his book did you I've never
met his book no and I thought that maybe
when I finished my one I'd read it I
mean his come out like 15 years ago yeah
I want him do you want him to read yours
I don't know I kind of leave that up to
him yeah I you know his book there's
just I know that if he and I sit and sit
in a room together and we talk about
stuff I know we're both gonna walk out
of that room and you have completely
different ideas about what happened in
the room yeah I mean we just that's how
we are we look at things he and I at
said point counterpoint point
counterpoint all the time or like always
at each other looking at things you know
no I feel misunderstood I feel
misunderstood this is how it is no you
know what I mean it's like but but but
in that year is like this yearning I I
feel so much love for me from him and
vice versa and we're always sort of like
you know figuring out how it works and I
think in that and I think it's like that
with most things in life then in the
trying to figure it out and in the
yearning and in the wanting to
understand is where great things happen